bonsoir ya qui ont payé au merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on a
évoqué évidemment début d'émeute rond
début de confinement quelle est la
situation aujourd'hui dans les prisons
est ce qu'elle s'est améliorée
je pense que les détenus comprennent
l'intérêt de d'impliquer confinement y
compris dans les établissements
pénitentiaires alors c'est sûr que les
établissements peuvent être en tension
notamment dans les maisons d'arrêt il ya
encore une surpopulation
lorsque les détenus soient plusieurs
dans une cellule il est bien évident que
le confinement est plus difficile à
supporter que lorsqu'un détenu est seul
en cellule et c'est le cas de la plupart
des maisons d'arrêt alors effectivement
le garde des sceaux par ordonnance a
pris des décisions notamment ne pas
exécuter les courtes peines libérer
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont moins
de deux mois de détention à effectuer et
puis également libéré détention
provisoire dans l'attenté du jugement
puis finalement il ya eu il ya une
activité judiciaire qui diminution ce
qui fait que actuellement les prisons
sont moins peuplées huit mille détenus
en moins et nous sommes sur un taux
d'occupation absence en 203 4 % c'est
vrai que c'est mieux en termes de
tension mais quand vont supprimer
effectivement les activités en prison
c'est compliqué aussi bien pour les
personnels que pour que pour les détenus
mais je crois qu'il faut protéger les
personnels pénitentiaires et c'est vrai
qu'ils ont il a fallu également qu'on
demande à ce que les personnels soient
mieux protégés dans leur mission de tous
les jours et puis également pour les
détenus qui sont suspectés d'avoir
effectivement attrapé ce virus avait
également de les mettre à l'isolément
total avec de la protection égale ment
voilà ça c'est un sujet qui est majeure
si on veut pas effectivement que le coc
vie de 19 se déplacent se développe dans
les établissements pénitentiaires des cd
du commis de
neuf ainsi que deux détenus comment
éviter cette propagation qui semble
pourtant inéluctable selon vous alors
moi je suis pas médecin mais je pense
qu'il faut absolument que tous les
agents soient équipés de matériel de
protection comme on le fait actuellement
dans certains établissements qui héberge
des personnes et je crois qu'il faut
absolument que saccageant et des masques
alors quand aux détenus bien si on peut
effectivement les doter également de
masques qui sortent leur cellule par
exemple ou lorsque ils ont une activité
pas collective mais lorsqu'elle est
détenu voie en cour de promenade
c'est également un moment délicat dans
dans la détention dont je crois qu'il
faut renforcer toutes les mesures pour
protéger à la fois les personnels et par
conséquent également les détenus pour
faire face à cette situation vous l'avez
dit 1,8 mille détenus on est ont été
libérés il ya moins de 1000 détenus en
moins dans les prisons françaises
faut-il s'en inquiéter
selon vous c'est une décision qui a été
critiqué un art certain
oui je vais le problème c'est quand même
notre coopération pénalties et on avait
suffisamment de prison en france est
suffisamment de place ces décisions
auraient pas été opportune bon moi je
pense que compte tenu de la conjoncture
actuelle je je je je pense que le garde
des sceaux a bien fait voilà mais il
faut regarder tous les détenus qui sont
qui ont été libérés les moines de moi il
faut vérifier à ce qu'il n'y ait pas eu
des détenus condamnés pour des faits de
violence pour des faits terroristes
effectivement c'est petit et c'est ce
qui m'a regardée et tous les phénomènes
de violence donc je pense que si ces
détenus qui sont en fin de peine et qui
ont eu par exemple un bon comportement
et qu'ils ont commis des délits qui met
pas forcément en jeu leur public
eh bien je pense que on prend moins de
risques et donc je crois que c'est en
matière de de mesurer les risques qu'il
faut qu'il faut raisonner
je pense que le garde des sceaux a bien
fait de prendre les dispositions qu'elle
vienne arrêté il ya quelques quelques
semaines voilà je crois que c'est plutôt
dans cet effet avec beaucoup de
réflexion ce n'est pas simple mais je
crois qu'il fallait quand même le faire
alors la droite a néanmoins vertement
critiqué cette décision le rn sans
surprise également eric ciotti selon lui
130 détenus radicaliser son dehors ce
que dément d'ailleurs nicole belloubet
qui dit vrai ce que vous vous avez par
hasard la réponse non je n'ai pas la
réponse mais je ne bois pas franchement
un établissement ou un magistrat libérés
avant sa fin de peine
un détenu qui a été impliqué dans une
affaire de terrorisme alors c je ne
comprends pas donc je crois que c'est il
ya eu des ordonnances très précisément
il est là si les détenus ont qui sont
confrontés et qui ont été confrontés
vois impliquées dans une affaire a
tourist qui s'ils ont été libérés
c'est parce qu'ils sont enfin le pen et
s'ils sont en fin de peine il peut ils
peuvent avoir effectivement des mesures
de contrôle judiciaire
lorsqu'ils seront mis en liberté mais
c'est uniquement dans ce cas de figure
mais il est bien évident que ce serait
pas acceptable qui a détenu même s'il
est en fin de peine soit libéré
lorsqu'il a commis par exemple des
violences sur les forces de l'ordre sur
les surveillants pénitentiaires
lorsqu'il a commis des violences assez
assez importante et avec des victimes
qui peuvent être toujours présent dans
l'environnement
ça c'est pas acceptable par contre
libérer un détenu il lui reste par
exemple quelques semaines a effectué par
ce qu'il a commis des vols ou parce que
effectivement il a commis un délit qui
met qui met pas en jeu leur public
on peut le comprendre on peut le
comprendre dans la conjoncture actuelle
et puis retardée effectivement
l'exécution des peines lorsque c'est pas
nécessaire c'est également une décision
que nous pouvons comprendre
donc moi j'essaie d'être pragmatique et
je pense que si les ordonnances du et
les directives du garde des sceaux sont
appliqués à la lettre je pense qu'il y
aura normalement il n'y a pas de
difficulté à la matière mais il faut que
ce soit bien appliquée il faut
effectivement les autorités
pénitentiaires et judiciaires soient
tout à fait vigilant lorsque ils
prennent la décision de libérer un
détenu en fin de peine merci beaucoup
qui
oyo députés ps d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france